the secretary general of the african
national congress
ace magashule is the highest ranking
member of the governing party
to be charged with fraud and corruption
the charges are linked to a
five-year-old project in the free state
province
the provincial government paid about 15
million dollars to a company
to remove asbestos sheeting from the
roofs of homes here
instead the money was stolen some of it
allegedly by magashule who was running
the provincial government at the time
bulenk outlet has lived in this
government subsidised home for more than
20 years
she says the asbestos roof has made her
ill
they were paid and they used the money
to fix their own homes and to buy
themselves fancy cars
they have no regard for us we still live
in these homes
a few doors down paseka seputla says his
family has lived in this home for 37
years
he says both his parents died from lung
disease
my mom and my dad they suffered
from the asbestos and they suffered a
lot because of
the one who postponed on in 2002 my
father then
he had tv related disease so
that's what happened he suffered a lot
then my mom
he suffered asthma people here say the
anc government
has done little to help them and many
blame magashule
but outside court thousands of people
came out to show their support for him
they say the charges are politically
motivated
there is not a single cent that i took
from government and i will reveal
everything in court
magazine has been released on bail and
is due to return to court in february
the anc has been facing internal power
struggles for some time
and many see the case as another
incident that exposes its divisions
president sila ramaphosa has promised to
clean up corruption
starting from within his own party but
ace magazine's appearance in court
is likely to further divide the african
national congress
that's already in crisis family
al jazeera blindfolded in the free state
province